[Música]
alguna vez donde nace el talento
si tuvieras que ubicarlo en algún lugar
de tu cuerpo donde sería
déjame adivinar lo que quizás estás
pensando en tu cerebro
y si es así estás en lo cierto no te
equivocas
ahora en cuál de ellos
imagino que has escuchado más de una vez
eso de tenemos dos cerebros
no arriba
y una bajo en nuestra barriga al que
llaman el segundo cerebro es así
pues me sabe mal decirte que no es así
nuestra barriga no es el segundo cerebro
lo siento
y es que cuando todos nosotros hemos
estado dentro de la barriga de mamá de
nuestra mamá en nuestra gestación cuando
éramos más pequeños que un garbanzo y no
teníamos ni forma humana de hecho
empezábamos a tener algo de forma humana
en ese preciso momento
el primer sistema nervioso que se formó
fue el sistema nervioso entérico y eso
quiere decir el sistema nervioso de la
barriga
por tanto podemos decir que nuestra
barriga no es el segundo cerebro nuestra
barriga es
el primer cerebro
y el talento nace en la barriga
no es casualidad que todo lo que
sentimos a día de hoy primero de todo
los sentimos dónde
en nuestra barriga
cuántas veces tras una discusión un
examen unas oposiciones o un cambio de
trabajo
nuestra función digestiva ha cambiado
radicalmente
eso quiere decir por ejemplo que hemos
tenido una diarrea
o si eres de esos que te cuesta ir de
vientre a diario
pero qué pasa la mañana antes de la
competición o de la reunión tan
importante con tu jefe
que parece que te hayas tomado una caja
de laxantes
o esa sensación de nudo en el estómago
cada vez que queremos invitar a ese
chico o esa chica que tanto nos gusta
para ir a cenar
o las veces que tenemos que ir de
vientre antes de esa entrevista tan
importante de trabajo
o esa sensación desagradable que tenemos
cuando sabemos que tenemos un problema
pendiente de resolver
hace unos años trate a una chica en mi
consulta maría
y seguramente es una historia que quizá
o resuena a vosotros mismos o algún
conocido o algún amigo
y es que maría vino a mi consulta
diagnosticada de colon irritable
no sé si os suena
colon irritable y no te asustes mucho
por el nombre de esta disfunción quiere
decir que el colon está algo inflamado o
algo irritado y que presenta una
sintomatología como distensión abdominal
hinchazón gases diarrea o estreñimiento
e incluso cólicos y es muy común
de hecho yo mismo en mi adolescencia me
diagnosticaron de colon irritable
ahora puedo decir que soy un ex colon
irritable
porque hace muchos años que ya no tengo
esa sintomatología mi barriga
pero sí que es muy común sobre todo en
nuestro mundo occidental
cuando miramos el mundo occidental
normalmente miramos los datos de eeuu y
sabéis qué
que hay 35 millones de personas acuden
al médico cada año
con el diagnóstico de colon irritable lo
que supone un gasto en sanidad de 20
billones de dólares billones con b de
baleares
una burrada
pues bien maría me explicó su caso y
claro me decía que esos síntomas que
tenía pues lo hacían sin vivir porque
porque tenía esa urgencia para ello el
baño y quizá estaban en una reunión en
el trabajo y lo pasaba muy mal
le pregunté a maría si había ocurrido
alguna cosa al inicio de sus síntomas
algún cambio en su vida y me dijo que sí
que cronológicamente es cuando empezó a
estar mal con su pareja
que discutían mucho que se sentía muy
sola y que lloraba horas sola en casa
además en esa época logró un importante
trabajo la administración pública con un
gran sueldo unas grandes condiciones
pero el jefe
no la trataba muy bien y la explotaba
laboralmente
y claro por un lado ella creía que no se
podía quejar al jefe porque tenía miedo
a las repercusiones y por otro lado
aunque ese trabajo no le apasionaba
porque la verdad es que no le hacía muy
feliz
creía que no podía cambiar porque claro
ya que tenía un trabajo quien se lo iba
a pensar
claro ahí hicimos cuentas echamos
cuentas y miramos todas las horas que
pasaba al día y a la semana con tensión
en su barriga
y os podéis imaginar entre trabajo y en
casa
bueno empezamos a tratar a maría y
empezamos a tratar su barriga maría
cambió su alimentación mejoró la
funcionalidad de su estómago y empezó a
reequilibrar los microorganismos de su
intestino
y en la tercera visita más o menos a los
4 o 5 meses desde la primera visita
maría me contó que sus síntomas
digestivos casi habían desaparecido en
su totalidad pero eso no fue muy curioso
lo más curioso fue que con mucha
tranquilidad maría me dijo xavi que he
dejado a mi pareja
sí sí y me siento muy bien me siento muy
tranquila una decisión de verdad muy
bien y además de habla con el jefe de
puesto los límites suficientes para no
sentirme explotaba laboralmente
y además xavi estoy pensando en un
proyecto de interiorismo porque es que a
mí me gusta el interiorismo bueno
lógicamente le di el alta porque porque
había mejorado todo
pero eso aún no fue lo más curioso sabes
lo que fue más curioso que
aproximadamente un año después me
escribió un correo electrónico
contándome que había dejado el trabajo
en administración pública y que se
sentía muy feliz porque ya llevaba unos
meses en su proyecto personal de
interiorismo y una posdata xavi mi
barriga también sigue muy feliz
eso es casualidad eso es causalidad que
creéis
porque bajo mi experiencia clínica a día
de hoy y después de haber tratado a
miles de pacientes durante muchos años
en mi consulta puedo decir que no hay
casualidad sino que es una gran
causalidad y es que el impacto que tiene
la salud digestiva en nuestra toma de
decisiones no es que sea grande es que
es enorme
porque el tubo digestivo es un órgano
neurológico
600 millones de neuronas pueblan el
aparato digestivo ya eso se le llama el
sistema nervioso entérico como he dicho
antes fijaros que esto es muy chulo el
cerebro recibe muchas muchas
informaciones muchos inputs del medio
externo de nuestro contexto y del medio
interno de nuestras vísceras y luego el
cerebro lo que hace es integrar todas
estas informaciones y genera una
respuesta esta respuesta puede ser un
cambio en la conducta o puede ser un
cambio en nuestro medio interno por
ejemplo cambiando el metabolismo de
nuestras vísceras
sabéis que entre el 60 y el 80 por
ciento de información que le llega del
medio interno al cerebro es del
intestino
os imagináis lo que es una inflamación
en este órgano
literalmente estamos expresando nuestro
cerebro y entorpeciendo nuestra conducta
de hecho las personas que tienen
inflamación en su aparato digestivo
pueden sentir más dolor
y es que una diana terapéutica en
pacientes aquejados de dolor crónico es
tratar su aparato digestivo
es que el aparato digestivo es un súper
comandante que no solo comanda nuestro
cerebro sino es que comanda nuestra toma
de decisiones lo que sentimos y lo que
pensamos
y yo me pregunto
hay vida allí
creéis que hay alguna forma de vida no
humana que resida en nuestros intestinos
claro aquí os tengo que presentar al que
conocemos como el órgano olvidado claro
olvidado porque sólo hace 15 años que en
investigación nos estamos dando cuenta
del impacto que tiene en nuestra salud
y es
microbiota intestinal guau con el nombre
aunque seguro que ya os suena algunos la
microbiota
lo podemos definir como el conjunto de
microorganismos o microbios o bichos que
residen en nosotros y seguro que suenan
algunos haber parásitos
hongos
virus bacterias
entre otros microorganismos y que forman
un ecosistema que reside en nosotros y
lógicamente que tenemos
microbiota en todo nuestro cuerpo pero
la gran metrópolis es nuestro intestino
de hecho en los últimos recuentos de
incidencia comparando con las células
humanas vemos que somos hay una relación
de dos uno de dos bichos uno células
humanas
todos nosotros somos más bichos que
humanos
incluso se han descrito unos 22.000
genes en el ser humano pero es que
podemos llegar a albergar hasta 2
millones de genes microbianos lo que
conocemos como el microbioma
2 millones de genes
y entre los bichos y nosotros tenemos
una relación simbiótica mutualista a ver
a ver a ver xavi qué es esto de una
relación simbiótica mutualista a los
nombres una relación simbiótica
mutualista es una relación de win-win
donde ganamos todos' donde yo me dedico
a cuidar y alimentar a mis bichos y
ellos se dedican a mantenerme con salud
parece ser ahora que el ser humano es
simplemente un almacén de bichos y
quizás quizás uno de los objetivos que
tenemos en la vida es transportar bichos
y es que están descritas más de 20.000
funciones de la microbiota intestinal y
seguramente de aquí 10 años habrán
30.000
y una de ellas es la que tenía el placer
de investigar en los últimos años en un
grupo de investigación es su relación
con el cerebro lo que conocemos como el
eje microbiota intestino cerebro
y que cuando miramos en investigación y
comparamos ratoncitos libres de gérmenes
se les llaman game free que no tienen
microbiota comparados con los ratoncitos
que sí que tienen microbiota
estos ratoncitos que no tienen
microbiota tienen su sistema nervioso
entérico completamente desorganizado
no sólo eso sino que su barrera
hematoencefálica que deseas también
tenemos nosotros los humanos si una
barrera hematoencefálica es una barrera
que protege de que las cosas malas no
pasen al cerebro que puedan dañar pues
esa barrera hematoencefálica también
está desorganizada en estos ratoncitos y
no sólo eso
es que los núcleos más importantes del
cerebro que tienen que ver con el
metabolismo con la memoria y con la
conducta también están desorganizados
en publicaciones recientes no solo en
modelos animales sino también en modelos
humanos se ha descrito que la micro vida
tiene que ver con otros aspectos como
por ejemplo la conducta sexual
el temperamento la interacción social
las adicciones
el aprendizaje y me permitís voy a abrir
un paréntesis os imagináis que en vez de
dar anfetaminas a los niños
diagnosticados de td a empezáramos a
mirar su tubo digestivo ya tratar su
salud digestiva
y lo dejó cerró el paréntesis
os imagináis que la microbiota tiene que
ver también con la memoria y con la
conducta de comer
y si alguna vez te ha apetecido ese
chocolate
ese azúcar se ensaimada ciclo a sanz es
el plato de pasta
creéis realmente crees realmente que nos
apetecía a vosotros
es que ahora sabemos que las necesidades
energéticas de nuestros bichos de
nuestros microbios envían una señal al
cerebro para que vayamos a buscar lo que
quieren ellos
es que tenemos que pasar ya del slogan
somos lo que comemos por somos lo que
nuestros bichos quieren que comamos
es así
además también tiene que ver con la
tolerancia al estrés tener una buena un
buen ecosistema bacteriano hace que nos
adaptemos mejor al estrés
claro pero queréis saber algo más
que cuando hay un desequilibrio de estos
microorganismos a eso se le llama
desvíos is es decir que han perdido ese
equilibrio en el ecosistema genera una
respuesta inflamatoria mediada por el
sistema inmunitario
y un secreto es que el sistema
inmunitario reside en nuestra barriga el
80 por ciento de todas las células
inmunitarias residen en nuestro tubo
digestivo por eso el intestino también
es un órgano inmunitario y cuando
tenemos ese desequilibrio de dichos y
generamos una inflamación el sistema
inmunitario produce unas sustancias que
se llaman citoquinas
y esas citoquinas son las proteínas
nuevas moléculas que relaciona el
sistema inmunitario con todo el resto y
rincones de nuestro cuerpo incluido
nuestro cerebro
por tanto podemos decir que cuando
tenemos inflamación
literalmente estamos inflamando nuestro
cerebro
estamos inflamando nuestra capacidad
energética estamos inflamando nuestra
alegría estamos informando nuestra toma
de decisiones
estamos inflamando nuestra capacidad de
expresar y desarrollar nuestros talentos
y si es tan importante entonces
la salud digestiva para el talento y la
toma de decisiones
yo quiero lanzar para acabar
una reflexión
y esa siguiente
nos planteamos a día de hoy
que cuidar nuestra barriga ya los que
habitan en ella
no es una mera opción no es ninguna moda
es una necesidad primaria para podernos
transformar en nuestra mejor versión
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]